let the final battle come it okay  you all right yeah I'm fine yeah what  have you chosen from the ladder so I  have um take some de special some  mustard and the the honey and I'm going  to do a honey and mustard glazed chicken  and chicken breast I'm going to make it  very very moist just like you're eating  a chicken thigh because I know the  recipes delete it but why not cook with  a thigh  no because that's how you amaze you  how's that made you we were gonna make  the depressed taste like a side  no no likes very moist I guess very  moist like I saw yeah what are you  suffering with that I'm serving that  with this and what the beans the beans  yes and I want to make a caramelized on  this one and honey  they have like this one helped me what  does that mean and onion paralyzed onion  I was trying to make a hollandaise I  don't think I've enough time you don't  really serve chicken with hollandaise  why but let's go fish one dish 25  minutes good luck